hallo leute in deutschland leben 58
prozent der menschen zur miete heute
möchten wir euch zeigen wie ihr euren
vermieter den hausmeister oder die
hausverwaltung kontaktieren könnt wenn
ihr in eurer mietwohnung oder eure
miethaus ein problem feststellt ihr habt
es gerade schon gehört vermieter
hausverwaltung hausmeister warum nicht
eine person das ist so weil viele haus-
und wohnungseigentümer die arbeit rund
um ihre immobilie an einer
hausverwaltung abgeben
diese unternehmen kümmern sich um alles
was die immobilie betrifft machen wir
nebenkostenabrechnungen informieren die
mieter wenn es ein problem im haus gibt
wenn zum beispiel baumaßnahmen anstehen
und kümmern sich um alles was die
wohnung oder das haus betrifft
wenn man also ein problem in seiner
wohnung oder seinem haus fest stellt
ruft man zunächst die hausverwaltung an
diese können einen an den richtigen
ansprechpartner weiterleiten
wir zeigen euch gleich drei gespräche
die sie mit der hausverwaltung dem
hausmeister und dem vermieter führt los
geht's
und hier ist isabelle schmidt
ich wohne in der waldstraße 3 wo noch 14
ich habe diverse probleme in der wohnung
die ich gerne melden möchte hallo
okay was können sie tun also zum einen
wird er die fassade von meinem fenster
neu gemacht und der lärm ist wirklich
unzumutbar
das ist jetzt schon mal zwei wochen der
fall und ich muss immer zum arbeiten die
wohnung verlassen das geht gar nicht
also ich möchte gerne eine mietminderung
von zehn prozent beantragen
dann ist meine heizung in der küche
kaputt und es ist wirklich kalt draußen
hier ist nämlich winter ich weiß sie
wohl auf malle aber vielleicht haben sie
ja auch schon mal was von winter gehört
also ich freue mich echt den arsch ab
entschuldigung also ich friere ja und
zum schluss noch etwas was mich echt
nervt ich wohne schon seit einem jahr
und ich habe noch keinen ordentlich
jetzt klingelschilder natürlich mein
name steht noch aus so einem klebeband
ok frau schmidt es tut mir leid dass sie
unzufrieden sind wir haben hier auf
mallorca auch winter gestern waren es 15
grad kalt was bezüglich der heizung und
das klingelschild würde sie gerne an
ihren hausmeister weiterleiten
sie haben die nummern der hilft ihnen
sicher gerne und bezüglich der
mietminderung müssen sie mit herrn monat
sprechen
ihr vermieter das kann nur er
entscheiden bitte rufen sie ihn dazu an
und warum sind sie dann die
hausverwaltung wenn sie mir über nichts
helfen können
ich helfe ihnen doch ich gebe ihnen
gerne nochmal die telefonnummern
die habe ich selber danke tschüss
der hausmeister die hausverwaltung der
vermieter jetzt seid ihr dran trainiert
mit dem gender trainer unserer app sieht
längen die artikel zu den wichtigsten
2000 deutschen probiert es einfach mal
aus in mehrfamilienhäusern gibt es
manchmal noch einen hausmeister dieser
kümmert sich um kleine reparaturen im
haus um die pflege der öffentlichen
bereiche
das haus flores des kellers oder
vielleicht des gartens diese person
kennen sich also im haus am besten aus
[Applaus]
schuld hallo guten tag hier ist isabelle
schmidt ich wohne in der waldstraße 3
wohnung 14
die hausverwaltung sagte mir ich darf
mich an sie wenden
ja was gibt es nun schon wieder ja also
das klingelschild wurde immer noch nicht
geändert ich bin ja jetzt schon vor
allem mehr eingezogen also dass wir echt
super wenn sie das jetzt mal bald
nachholen können
sie rufen mich wegen einem klingelschild
glauben sie ich habe sonst nichts zu tun
ja es gibt ja auch noch eine sache die
heizung in meiner küche ist kaputt ich
friere ja dann drehen sie durch die
heizkörper in den anderen räumen auf das
passt dann zu ich möchte aber gerne
funktionierende heizkörper meiner
wohnung so habe ich die wohnung gemietet
ich möchte gleich merzig heizen und
nicht meine heizkosten in die höhe
treiben
mayotte dann leitet ihr problem ich in
die halle weiter der macht bei uns die
heizungs geschichten der soll
vorbeikommen wenn er in der nähe ist
okay besten dank und das klingelschild
ja das klingelschild kriegen sie auch
wenn sie das glücklich macht ja macht es
danke auf wiederhören mit dem vermieter
hat man meistens gar nicht so viel
kontakt man trifft den vermieter
eventuell bei der wohnungsübergabe
sicherlich auch bei vertragsschluss aber
selbst die wohnungsübergabe übernehmen
meistens die haushaltungen bei einzug
und auch bei auszug
andré monnet hier was gibt's hallo hier
ist isabelle schmidt
ich wohne in der waldstraße 3 wohnung 14
die hausverwaltung sagte mir ich kann
mich an sie wenden
ok-präsident ja also die fassade vor
meinen fans dann wird erneuert und das
ist ein unglaublicher lärm
ich muss jetzt da zwei wochen zum
arbeiten das haus verlassen und wollte
mich gerne mal erkundigen ob sie mir für
diese zeit zehn prozent mietminderung
geben können eine mietminderung wollen
sie so was habe ich noch nie gehört
die so was machen wir nicht also wenn es
ihn in berlin zu laut ist müssen sie
vielleicht mal brandenburg ziehen oder
so also tut mir leid ich habe mich aber
informiert ich kann laut gesetzgeber
sogar viel mehr verlangen
mit den zehn prozent möchte ich ihnen
aber entgegenkommen wissen sie was frau
schmidt ich bin jetzt zu einem whisky
tasting eingeladen und habe eigentlich
keine lust mich damit zu beschäftigen
wir machen das so ich schalte mein
anwalt einlass das von dem regeln und
sie hören man von uns zurück ja
wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]
keine sorge nicht jeder hausmeister oder
vermieter ist so unfreundlich wie in
diesem beispiel gerade ich hoffe aber
dass sie einige vokabeln für gespräche
rund um eure mietwohnung lernen konnte
um euer deutsch weiter zu verbessern
probiert doch mal unsere app sie länger
aus wie eben schon gesagt könnt ihr dort
zum beispiel mit dem gender trainer die
artikel zu den wichtigsten 2000
deutschen lernen
schaut einfach mal rein bis bald wieder
auf die lieder hören nein
ok auf wiederhören
[Musik]